pour éponger des déversements pétroliers
que ce soit celui du deepwater horizon
dans le golfe du mexique ou à plus
petite échelle de la rivière chaudière à
mégantic
on utilise généralement des rouleaux de
polypropylène un produit synthétique une
firme de granby propose un produit
beaucoup plus absorbant et 100% naturel
la fibre d'ascq les piannencs nous avons
essayé la trop stationnaire ou françois
simard produira plus de 800 de ses
trousses d'urgence grandes et petites
qui seront déployés dans 54 parcs
nationaux du canada en cas de
déversement pétrolier accidentelle
salam et quantix aurait été utile
j'imaginais ah oui totalement parce que
ça tombe très vite en apprend beaucoup
moins que qu'un produit de ces tubes
sont remplies de fibres d'ascq les
piannencs produit de cette plante qui
pousse à l'état sauvage et qui a été
récolté pour la première fois cet
automne à échelle industrielle au québec
par canada entrepose des carburants pour
ses flottes de véhicules et pour le
chauffage et l'électricité des bâtiments
bien souvent près de la côte cours d'eau
il ya donc des risques de fuite ou de
déversement mineurs les experts de parcs
canada ont été surpris par l'efficacité
de la fibre d'azpeitia on laboratoire
dit il ce produit est cinq fois plus
efficace que le produit synthétique à
danoise
premièrement la fibre d'ascq les
piannencs n'absorbe jamais l'eau on
constate que löw veut pas rentrer du
tout dans la faible et se retrouve en
dessous dans le bac
le produit est très réfractaire à l'eau
me procure sa flottabilité autre
avantage mais surtout elle absorbe
l'huile de façon unique ici du diesel un
litre d'huile que nous versons sur
semène 30 g de boudin constitué fait
d'azpeitia quelques minutes vraiment à
rien car ce roadshow voilà nous avons
ici le résultat si on garde entre n'ya
pas d'huile qui a passé à travers sur un
petit goût d'un psy même exercice mais
cette fois avec 70 g de polypropylène le
matériau le plus efficace utilisé
couramment pour les déversements un bon
tiers du diesel passe à travers
nettement moins efficace que la sq les
biens on n'a pas la capacité d'absorber
inde est complètement la semdas l'épia
d' al avantage sur la fée de
polypropylène qui le produit communément
utilisé pour les déversements pétroliers
d'être creuse donc elle est beaucoup
plus les gens mais l'analyse peut être
absorbé autour de la feb donc à
l'intérieur des interstices d'un lot de
films et aussi à l'intérieur ce qui fait
que c'est inégalée dans le monde avoir
une capacité d'absorption aussi élevé
que l'as les piannencs c'est à dire 40
fois son poids
ça veut dire qu'un seul kg d'acier piane
peut absorber 50e ville alors qu'un kilo
de polypropylène peut en absorber dix
parcs canada a noté un autre avantage
écologique au projet donc il y avait
aussi un effet parallèle que ce produit
proviendrait d'une fibre naturelle
provenant d'une plante qui estime
billettique m'a associé avec le papillon
monarque est le pensions car son
l'asclépiade qui est à la fois son
habitat et sa nourriture
le monarque ne peut pas survivre il
vient de terminer sa longue migration il
s'apprête à passer l'hiver dans les
sapins ou via mail des montagnes
centrale du mexique
les experts ont constaté que la coupe
illégale des sapins avaient diminué de
moitié
bonne nouvelle les homards vidal du
world wildlife fund
mais les pays du nord
sur lesquels se trouve le corridor du
monarque pourrait mieux faire à ses
espoirs sont minces et aux implantations
il faudrait dit-il une plantation
massive d'ascq les pianos états unis
pour que le monarque s'ils nourrissent
et se reproduisent sinon leur nombre
continuera à diminuer au dernier sommet
de l'alena
les trois leaders nord-américains ont
fait un pas de géant en créant pour la
première fois un groupe de travail sur
le papillon monarque
la présidente de la commission de
l'environnement de l'alena s'en réjouit
et voit dans le projet de granby un
précédent utile c'est une entreprise
commerciale
elle utilise l'asclépiade dont dépend le
papillon et en même temps elle développe
son produit
c'est gagnant gagnant les producteurs de
granby ne manque pas d'ambition et voit
l'expérience de parcs canada comme un
tremplin
nous voyons bien qu'avec le déploiement
de nos champs d'astellia dès la
disponibilité accrue de la fibre au fait
des années que la stévia devienne le
produit par excellence pour l'absorption
des hydrocarbures d'autant plus que
c'est un produit naturel qui ne provient
pas du pétrole comme le polypropylène
alors ça fait un peu ironique de devoir
produire du pétrole pour ramasser les
déversoirs pétrole ceci pourrait être le
début d'une opération doublement
bénéfique d'abord protéger
l'environnement cas de déversement de
façon plus efficace est aussi rentable
et ensuite des plantations à échelle
industrielle de la matière première
pourrait assurer l'avenir de l'habitat
du papillon monarque à travers toute
l'amérique du nord